[Music]
three friends trapped in a house of
dread
lessons taught will fill their head
[Music]
one a duck the other red
[Music]
and the last the yellow guy is
dead
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that knows that a family is
just a group of people who live together
and have the same lawyer ladies and
gentlemen it happened the new Don't Hug
Me I'm Scared TV series has finally hit
the airwaves and it is great to catch
you up don't hug me I'm scared or dhmis
for sure started as a series of YouTube
videos that took Sesame Street and
jigsaw and then made the two of them
kiss the YouTube series followed three
protagonists named red guy yellow guy
and duck as they went on adventures
learned important lessons about things
like
then injected pure nightmare fuel into
her eyeballs with imagery like this
[Music]
the series concluded in 2016 most of us
thought that it had entered the great
YouTube playlist in the sky lost
alongside Nigahiga and Jenna Marbles
faded to occasionally pop up in
recommended feeds from now until the
heat death of the universe whenever the
algorithm sensed that we are starting to
get nostalgic or at least that's the way
it was supposed to go until Don't Hug Me
did The Impossible and got a TV show
earlier this year the creators managed
to Wrangle together a real six episode
dhmas TV series on the British Channel
4. and after watching it I gotta say it
Nails the tone of those original YouTube
videos all without feeling held back or
tied down by them in fact it's clear
that while the Aesthetics look the same
the series has moved on the calendar
that appears in every episode has moved
from the original June 19th date that it
was stuck on to June 20th it's a turning
of the page a symbolic New Leaf and
whereas the original series was all
about the corruption of Art and children
programming this new TV series seems to
tell a more personal story about these
characters because they are actual real
characters now no longer are they just
symbols for kids or creators or Ducks I
guess these three now appear to have
histories
in fact when you start piecing this
puzzle together the story of these three
characters is tragic they're a trio
that's trapped inside of a repeating
cycle built on one woman's guilt and
pain and if I'm right about this at
least one of these three characters is
dead so wakey wakey gang it's Theory
time just Theory time you'll see for the
first four episodes of the show things
proceed normally or at least as normally
as they can for the world of dhmis our
three characters start each day in some
mundane way before eventually being
joined by the teacher of the week and
anthropomorphized object that's there to
share some Twisted lessons about topics
ranging from jobs to death to
electricity oh sure there's some weird
bits mixed in there like yellow guy's
dad Roy viciously ripping apart a creepy
family or duck killing off his own
doppelganger but nothing that out of the
ordinary but then comes episode 5 where
we see the reality of the show starting
to fray in this episode our main
characters are confronted by an old
living train basically the nursing home
equivalent of Thomas the Tank Engine
Thomas the Hoveround engine anyway at
one point the teacher turns into a car
and then promptly dies so our heroic
trio does the reasonable thing and hops
into his rotting carcass to take a road
trip and it works not only do they
manage to drive past the desiccated
remains of their original TV pilot oh
I'm sorry that place doesn't exist
anymore well what happened to it just
shriveled they managed to drive so far
that they break through what appears to
be a simulation they leave their
cartoonish World Behind only to end up
in a realistic dystopian one we can't go
back I'm not going back
there's something out there
[Music]
lost and confused they set up camp for
the night as they sit around a fire
contemplating their new world and hoping
that the neighbors will show up to help
a mysterious voice begins to echo
through the night
suddenly yellow guys see something out
of the corner of his eye and we cut to
black only to then watch as a mysterious
hand rolls a model of their car up to a
dollhouse the same house that we've been
watching at the start of every episode
The Journey always ends up back at home
now this is important because earlier
this very episode the characters had
already talked about the episodic nature
of content and how everything always
winds up resorting to a status quo all
we do is sit around and then some guy
comes and tells us about Banks or
vegetables nice to be back at home eh
what are you talking about we didn't
even go anywhere and sure enough when we
rejoined them in episode six the
characters are reset right back to where
we started none the wiser about their
junkyard Excursion the night before and
that's when things start to really pick
up at first the season finale is all
about electricity our three friends get
an electric bill and they don't want to
pay it because electricity is silly
stuff that ought to be friends so of
course their fuse box electricity comes
to life to teach him more about the
wonders of electricity and how it Powers
phones and televisions and radios
[Music]
and yes even your Shredder when the
lesson suddenly turns to Portable
sources of energy like batteries yellow
guy gives us the surprise Revelation
that he too is powered by batteries no I
am half factories see
which is a strange detail that we'll
come back to regardless his current
batteries are old corroded and clearly
out of juice so duck switches him out
for elect traces suddenly the once doofy
yellow guy is Juiced up to the Max and
instead of being dimwitted his mind
explodes with intelligence equipped with
this new awareness of the world around
him yellow guy becomes the first person
of the trio to realize that they're only
on the bottom floor of what's a
multi-story house yellow guy climbs the
stairs to discover the big boy room on
the second floor inside he finds older
versions of red guy and duck that are
able to learn not just one but two
lessons in a given day you same bake
yeah we're big boys big boys try and
keep up mate unimpressed he continues up
to the third floor where he finds the
more advanced bigger boy his room
housing even smarter and more futuristic
versions of red guy and duck eventually
he's turned off by their heartless and
cruel experiments things like
electrocuting an innocent lump of living
flesh so for a final time yellow guy
leaves the room and moves up another
flight of steps at the top of the house
things are extremely different here
yellow guy finds a door labeled Leslie
and we immediately get an answer as to
what that means on the other side
to me it's made clear that this is the
woman that we heard reciting the rhyme
at the end of episode 5. it was also her
gloved hand that was resetting the
dollhouse back to square one at the end
of the last episode but now the
dollhouse is opened and we can see small
figures of the trio inside recreating
the exact events that we're watching
play out in this episode yellow guy is
obviously full of questions and Leslie
promises to answer all of them provided
he plays with the dolls you help me tidy
things up around here and I'll help you
you promise
promise she then produces a large
leather-bound book covered in a wacky
looking code before sending him back
downstairs to his friends right as he's
about to read it duck and red guy ripped
the batteries out of his chest in order
to power the house yellow guy forgets
what the book was for in the first place
and decides that it's something
incredible the season ends as the three
friends cheer at the destruction of the
book so close to answers or even an
escape but instead trapped inside their
ceaseless prison once more making
matters worse yellow guy never realized
that there was yet another level to the
house that he never got to it's an
incredibly sad surreal ending to the
season which leaves us on this unusual
Cliffhanger can yellow guy make the
journey up the stairs again based on the
pictures that we see behind him hanging
on the wall as he goes up we know that
he's made this journey before hopefully
there's a second season where he's able
to do the whole thing again in the
meantime though we're left with a lot of
questions the first and foremost being
who or what is Leslie she's the only
human character that we meet throughout
all of dhmas which in and of itself is
her design is also noteworthy she's a
bizarre mix of puppet and flesh she's
clearly a human but her coat makes her
look like one giant Muppet that's
covered in fur and her face has been
stitched and scarred like a creature
that's been sewn together more
importantly than her design though she
acts like the Puppeteer for this world
she's the one that's turning the crank
at the start of every episode she also
appears to be controlling the actions of
all the others through her miniature
figurines and when one of the Dolls
breaks she has a drawer full of
Replacements nope sorry don't worry I
always make sure that I have plenty of
backups well I suspect that I know
what's going on here and it all begins
with one key line as Leslie sends yellow
guy in his way he asks whether he can
stay on the top floor with her she
immediately rejects the idea by shouting
you're not my real song
only joking at first this just seems
like a random Outburst a combination
punchline jump scare to keep us on our
feet but I think that this is actually
the key to understanding everything
about this new series taking Leslie at
her word here yellow guy isn't her real
son but he's close you see I suspect
that yellow guy represents Leslie's real
son a real son named David a son who
died
in episode 2 death we see the name David
etched onto the grave where duck gets
buried why does it say David later we
see a large group of human mourners show
up in the kitchen for David's funeral
where they again mistake duck for David
we're just friends friends of day it
wasn't cool David so what would make me
say that yellow guys David well take a
look at what's stitched into yellow
guy's overalls on the front pocket
there's the large letter D and at the
foot of yellow guy's bed the letter D
again in episode three family yellow guy
is even given a special locket with the
letter D engraved on it over and over
again yellow guy and the letter D are
connected D for David but the connection
between the two goes well beyond just
the letter going back to the death
episode when our happy Trio first show
up at the cemetery the coffin assumes
that yellow guy is the one who died
don't tell me I'm good at this it's you
isn't it and throughout the rest of the
series we watch as both flies and worms
are attracted to yellow guy and no one
else it's almost like he's a dead
decaying body plus there's a strange
moment in the intro of episode 5 where
yellow guy seems to dissociate and
remember something about his past
like there was another mate he's clearly
remembering a dream where he saw another
version of himself he's seeing David the
same thing happens again later that same
episode when he looks out the car window
when I look out through it it looks back
in through me he's connecting with a
past iteration of himself with David
we're also explicitly told that David is
not duck's name why does it say David
that's his name what that's supposed to
be your name we also know that red guy
isn't dead based on his ID don't be
silly you don't die for ages so by
process of elimination if one of these
characters is representative of David it
has to be yellow guy this may also
explain why Leslie says this to him when
he first enters the room
sounds almost motherly but this is far
from the full story The Tragic Twist of
the tale is that we know exactly what
killed David he died in a car crash in
episode 5 when red guy tells yellow guy
that they're going to be part of a
community yellow guy fantasizes about
living in a new city named mulhoven he
imagines joining a neighborhood
befriending the people of the Town
yellow guy then moves into a new home
where red guy's his neighbor and duck is
his pet everything is great until a
clergyman offers yellow guy a bird as a
welcome present the bird flies away and
yellow guy gives Chase into the street
from there you can guess the rest yellow
guy is hit by a car I suspect that dream
sequence may be more true to life than
we initially expect listen to the
narrator of that little story
here in mulhu for Newtown it's Leslie's
voice you've got plenty of reading to do
in fact it's Leslie screaming for yellow
guy to get out of the street oh careful
and the reason she's screaming because
she's the one in the car Leslie killed
her own son David
what did you say yeah you heard me
Leslie killed her own son in this
accident why do I say that well first of
all when we meet Leslie in episode 6 her
face is covered in stitches almost like
she went through an awful accident
herself secondly take a look at the
license plate of the car that the gang
drives throughout this episode it spells
Leslie and most importantly of all we
know that David wasn't the only person
in the family involved in a car crash
that day at the end of episode 3 as
they're wrapping up what they learned
about families yellow guy describes a
family as a group and dying the same day
in the same style of accident but in
different location unless his father Roy
also died in a car accident that same
day which seems pretty unlikely I
suspect that this Line's meant to
describe Leslie who metaphorically died
that day and you see that gets to the
core issue here that's why I think she's
created these characters this dollhouse
this world it's to escape from that
trauma the sad truth of Don't Hug Me I'm
Scared is that it isn't the story of
three wacky puppets learning disturbing
life lessons in reality it's the story
of a mother grieving over her dead son a
woman that is stuck in a spiraling cycle
of guilt creating play things that
represent him so she can impart all the
lessons that she would have taught him
if he had lived and she has dozens of
backups to ensure that she never loses
him again and for as much as yellow guy
reminds her of her lost son he can never
truly be the real David you're not my
son don't hug me I'm scared it's a weird
name right we've never really stopped to
question it have we it's always just
kind of been there so yeah dhms that's
the name duh but really think about
those words don't hug me I'm scared it's
a reference to someone so damaged so
hurt that they're afraid of something
like a hug they're scared of affection
Love of opening themselves up to someone
else that right there that's that's
Leslie afraid to love again because
she's afraid of being a hurt again but I
suspect that in order to move forward to
get to that final level of the house
that's exactly what needs to happen a
hug Leslie to forgive herself and yellow
guy to give her a hug then and only then
will both of them be able to transcend
to move past their stagnant lives inside
that house and climb to the final level
to finally be free but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory and a guts
[Music]
[Music]